le parti républicain aux états-unis est en
train de passer un mauvais moment
à la chambre des représentants
qu'est-ce qui se passe
un petit retour sur comment fonctionne le gouvernement
des états-unis
aux états-unis
le pouvoir législatif
c'est-à-dire le pouvoir de faire des lois et partager
par trois instituts
le président des etats-unis
le sénat et la chambre des représentants
et le seigneur et la chambre des représentants
ensemble forment le congrès
ceux qui font les lois
mais le président des états-unis joue
aussi un rôle législatif
parce qu'il peut imposer un véto ou
refuser d'appliquer les lois votées par le congrès
la chambre des représentants c'est un sentiment
l'équivalent des états-unis
de notre chambre des communes à ottawa
ou de notre assemblée nationale à québec
sauf qu'évidemment aux états-unis
ils ont aussi un sénat élu
chose que nous on a pas
à ottawa il y a un sénum il est pas élu et un québec
il y a pas de scénario du tout
il y a eu quelques mois des élections de mimos
qui touche surtout les représentants
parce que tous les représentants
doivent être élus à tous les deux
selon la constitution des états-unis
une des premières choses que les représentants doivent
faire c'est choisir un speaker
président de la chambre des représentants
à ne pas confondre avec le président des états-unis
évidemment encore une fois
ça c'est très similaire à notre système
la première chose que les députés doivent faire
que ce soit ottawa ou à
québec c'est choisir le président de la chambre l'eau
cette différence
c'est que chez nous
le président de la chambre des communes à ottawa
ou le président de l'assemblée nationale québec
sont des rôles qui ont pas beaucoup de pouvoir
les présidents sont surtout là pour sasuke
des bosses déroulent bien et généralement
ils sont neutres et non partisans
mais le président de la chambre des représentants
aux états-unis a beaucoup de pouvoir
c'est généralement lui qui décide
lors dans laquelle les projets
lois vont y déposer
quelles lois vont être débattues
et qu'un les votes vont être tenus
pour voir le généralement
il exerce de façon partisane
pour le bien de la jungle législative de son parti
il faut se dire que présentant
les démocrates détiennent la présidence des états-unis
et la majorité oceanos
qui veut dire que la charte des représentants
est la seule place
où les républicains peuvent faire avancer
leurs agents de législatif
parce que les républicains ont eu une majorité
à la chambre des représentants
aux dernières élections de mimanda
mais c'est une très faible majorité
il faut deux-cent-dix-huit sia
avoir la majorité à la chambre des représentants
et les républicains
anciennes présentant deux-cent-vingt-deux
normalement
l'élection du président de la chambre des représentats
est une formalité
les démocrates et les républicains
ils proposent chacun un quinze dates
tous les démocrates votent pour le quinze
de démocrates
tous les républicains
ils votent pour le quinze républicains
et la majorité l'emporte
alors hier quinze
putain de voter
pour le président de la chambre des représentants
c'est-ce que les démocrates ont fait
ont présenté l'heure quinze de hakim jeff reese
et tous les deux-cent-douze démocrates
ont voté pour lui
mais chez les républicains
ça s'est pas passé de mal
dix-neuf républicains qui ont voté contre le quinze
doc proposé par le parti républicain
kevin mcgraffey
ces dix-neuf représentants républicains
love viennent de l'aile un peu plus extrême du
parti républicain
trouvent que monsieur mccaretti est un peu trop centré
c'est trop modéré à leur goût
ce qui veut dire que
kevin mccaretty aurait reçu deux-cent-trois votes
et y avait pas de majorité
pour le président de la chambre des représentants
ça c'est la première fois en plus que cent ans
que c'est arrivé
en soi c'est pas grave selon les règles hein
le vote donne pas une majorité
les représentants
apprennent une pause et reviennent pour
voter plus tard
et ça donne un représentant
le temps de négocier
entre eux pour essayer d'arriver un candidat
qui va faire la majorité
depuis hier il y a eu onze votes